let's hear from a few more people in the
audience how about Ramiro from Indiana
welcome back to the program sir
Ramiro please accept my invitation to
join the program there he is
there sorry about that
so uh my quick question is uh so Donald
Trump everything going on obviously we
know
um there's nothing in place that would
prevent him from running for president
even from prison correct that's that's
my understanding yeah
so
um is that is there a reason for is it
simply because there isn't a specific
law in the books for that or is it a
conscious effort to say prevent
something like uh let's for example if
Donald Trump well when he won in 2016
let's say 2020 he was running against
Hillary again and he was afraid that she
would beat him so like he would jail his
political prisoner like saying lock her
up
in an attempt to
I guess so is that the reason something
like that a law preventing that from
happening isn't in place that's a good
question which is is the reason why
you're allowed to run for president from
prison that it prevents someone from
jailing a political opponent to get them
out of a race yeah so that's not my
understanding of the reasoning why I I
think the reasoning is a lot kind of
less less uh um uh exciting which is the
principle of law that if something isn't
banned then it's allowed and since
nothing expressly bans someone from
being in prison and running for
president it's allowed we've never
really had a situation in which I think
someone would actually have a shot at
winning the way Trump would but I'll be
honest Romero it's a very interesting
question I don't think it's going to
play out in any real way because I don't
think Trump's going to be in prison no
and I don't either yeah I don't either
but um I guess I wanted to know your
opinion do you think that that loss
should be in place or like I said do you
think it shouldn't be in place to
possibly prevent something like a
bolsonaro trying to jail Lula de Silva
and all that stuff generally speaking
generally speaking I'm okay with the
requirements to be president being super
super basic now remember I'm not allowed
to run for president because I wasn't
born in the United States I could make
the argument actually that should be
changed but forget about me I'm not even
arguing just in general you know age
natural born citizen okay I actually
think that I don't want to be putting a
whole bunch of new requirements on
although I am obviously ideologically uh
interested in the idea of some kind of
compass competency test which might have
ruled out Donald Trump but the one thing
that's a little crazy for me is if in
some states if you're a felon you can't
vote but yet you could be a convicted
felon and people vote for you and you
win something about that seems a little
incongruous you know it's weird
yeah yeah that's funny and that's why I
asked the question because if you would
have asked me before 2016 yeah I would
have said yeah no you should absolutely
not be able to run for president if
you're in jail but then I got to
thinking I'm like right we you know was
him running his campaign screaming lock
her up lock her up and I got to thinking
you know maybe that's maybe it's a good
thing that that's not on the books but
it is funny that you can be in prison
and not be allowed to vote after you get
out it's yeah yeah there's a lot of
these weird incongruous things but it's
I think the point we both Come Away with
is the next 18 months are going to be
pretty insane
yeah absolutely all right my friend
thank you for the call appreciate it
there's uh Ramiro from Indiana why don't
we go next to Casey from Kansas Casey
from Kansas welcome back to the program
hello
yeah I just have a simple question this
time since I think you already covered
it a little bit on your show
uh do you think what the win of Brandon
Johnson in Chicago against his more
tough on crime more police
endorsed by the Fraternal Order
candidate do you think that could make
Democrats like Joe Biden rethink their
tough on crime pivot
maybe you know go to a more solve it
from The Roots type of thing
why would so you're saying the fact that
Brandon Johnson won with his we're gonna
reform but support police sort of
mentality would that make Biden change
his mind about his approach why would it
make Biden change his mind
well I mean Biden has seemed like he's
going for a more traditional tough on
crime type of thing
oh I see at least no you know why I
don't think that would really influence
Biden much what makes sense politically
at the city level is different than what
makes sense at the state level and
certainly for running as as a
presidential campaign so I don't think
Biden would be moved much by what worked
in Chicago for a mayoral race
what about like other you know City
Democrats like Eric Adams or somebody
like that that may be that may be that
it could although all of these Mayors
often think and it might be true that
their City's circumstances are different
than others and so they really shouldn't
go by what other Mayors do it's just a
kind of a general thought that often is
in mayor's Minds
okay well I guarantee that if the
opposite had happened and if Paul vallas
had one that people like Eric Adams
would be shouting from the rooftops like
this is proof that yeah Democrats need
to get more tough on crime we need
harsher you know charges for felons and
everything like that you're probably
right you're probably right as far as
that goes yeah no but I don't expect to
see Biden adjust much as a on the basis
of what happened in Chicago to answer
the first question
yeah well I wish he would but yeah I
guess he'll probably continue as he's
going into 2024. I believe so Casey from
Kansas always great to hear from you
okay thank you all right there he goes